Hello, everybody.
Good afternoon
and welcome to the
lecture on clinical
decision making.
My name is Dr. Richard
Morgan. I'm the DPR1
coordinator. And
what I'm going to be
doing today is presenting
a lecture on really
the thought process
that goes behind how
we work through a case.
You know, we've done
a little bit of the
ICC patient encounters.
We've started to
work on soap note
writing. We're going
to go into a little bit
more on illness scripts.
But what this lecture
really entails is
the systems, the
thought processes by
which we as physicians go
through to come to the
ultimate conclusion
about what our
diagnosis and ultimately
our plan is going to
be with each patient.
So what are the
objectives for today? At
the conclusion of
today's session, the
students should be able
to, one, define dual
process theory of
cognition. We'll go
over both system one
and system two as the
leading model for
explaining clinical
decision making.
We'll be able to apply
these concepts of
problem representation,
illness scripts, and
pattern recognition.
Three, we'll demonstrate
knowledge and
application of
diagnostic reasoning
processes. And four,
we will distinguish
between the different
types of clinical
cognitive errors
that sometimes people
make on a basic
clinical vignette.
Now, as physicians,
we gather history
and perform an
appropriate physical exam
based on the reason
for the patient
seeking care, right?
So the first thing we
do is analyze the
findings to identify
potential causes for
the patient system
using our clinical
reasoning skills.
The potential
causes become our
differential diagnosis,
the possibilities
for what brings
the patient to your
office based on that
cheap complaint.
Your list always
starts with the most
likely, including
other plausible options
that will explain
the patient systems.
And it can include
diagnoses that
might have serious
complications or
consequences if
missed, because you
certainly don't want
to miss those at all.
For example, patient
with acute chest pain
rating to the left
shoulder should be
thought of as an MI
until proven otherwise.
You don't want to
miss something that is
potentially life
-threatening or lethal
if not diagnosed and
treated immediately.
Now, clinical
reasoning and clinical
decision-making is
based on two pathways.
So the first
pathway is, if you
look at this
slide to the left,
is more of the
intuitive system.
It's a faster system
that uses something
called heuristics.
which is mental
shortcuts. And we'll
get into that a
little bit more in
the coming slides.
It's something that
builds up over time
that physicians tend
to utilize after
years of practice,
years of experience. You
start to build up
a knowledge base of
all the past cases,
all the knowledge put
together through
schooling, residency,
fellowships, whatever
you might have
done. And over the
hundreds and hundreds of
patients that you
start to see, you
start to come to a
hypothesis very quickly.
And that's part of
the intuitive system
that utilizes
heuristics. As I said,
I'll get into that a
little bit more. The
second pathway to
the right here is the
hypothetico
-deductive pathway.
This is a much slower
pathway. It uses more
logic, more probability
to come to a
conclusion or diagnosis.
Now, this is the
system as you're starting
out first, second,
third, fourth year
medical school, you're
still building up your
knowledge base. It's
a slower pathway, but
it uses more logic
and probability to
come to that conclusion
or diagnosis. This
is the more likely
system for most of
people who will utilize
this type of staging
at this level of
education, because you're
still building your
knowledge base. And
this will help you
discern various seized
processes a little bit
slower, but a little
bit more logically.
Once you're in
practice, however, most
physicians will
regularly move between
both systems one
and system two with
their clinical decision
-making process.
Now, as I said,
heuristics,
that system one
involves mental
shortcuts. It's
used to assist a
clinician to rapidly
make decisions.
It's generally
subconsciously formulated in
a response patterns
based on formed habits.
You see something,
you get familiar with
it, you intuitively
know what it might be.
It's also, of course,
subject to error
because of a lot of
our cognitive biases.
And I'll give you
an example here.
I'd like you all to look
at this three pictures.
Now, what are these
three pictures of?
I'll give you a moment.
now obviously you look
at these three things
these three objects
if you will and we we
know that they're chairs
okay this is part of
that heuristic system
that i was talking
about before through
all of your experiences
as adults you've seen
many chairs you've seen
hundreds if not thousands
of chairs you've
sat in chairs you become
familiar with them
you know what they're
about you know what
they're utilized for
you have a good sense of
a working knowledge of
how they're utilize.
However, if you take
a child, you know,
a very, very young
child or an infant,
however, they may not
know what these are.
They haven't had those
life experiences.
They haven't had
the chance to sit in
as many chairs or
see as many chairs as
they would have, you
know, if they were
much, much older. But
like I said, that will
build up over time.
Therefore, when you
see these chairs,
you're using more of
the heuristic sense
of thought process.
And a young child
who does not,
is not familiar
with these,
is more likely
to use System 2.
Hopefully, this
example will help.
Okay, so what are we
going to be doing for
the remainder of this
time? We're going
to be breaking down,
okay, the key elements
of clinical decision
making, okay? We
follow a same pathway,
and we're going to
break each of these
down, starting from the
patient's story all
the way down to the
diagnosis, and how do
we configure and put
all these things
together? What are the
key elements of clinical
decision-making?
The first part is
the patient's story.
Now, a famous person
once said, if you
listen to your patient
tell their story,
they will also tell
you the diagnosis.
And that is
relatively true.
I would say the
majority, especially
within the subjective
component of any
patient interview,
most well-versed
clinicians and well
-knowledged clinicians
should be able to
identify the information
that will lead to
the diagnosis in
most cases just
from the subjective.
Let's look at the
patient's story.
Gathering that
initial health history
and physical exam.
Now, we started going
into this when we've
been in the ICC
recently, and we
started doing this with
some of the soap note
writing in class.
Gathering this
initial health history
involves the symptoms
elicited during
history. What brings
the patient to
your office today?
What are the key
elements? And what
are the associated
symptoms with that
chief complaint?
What are some of
the signs that are
both normal and
abnormal observed during
the physical exam?
In other words,
what are the pertinent
positives and
negatives that you
can elicit that
would help you come
to the diagnosis?
Then with the
laboratory or diagnostic
reports that they may
have had in the recent
past, you can also
combine those with
the other elements
from the subjective
history to help confirm
whatever diagnosis
you might be thinking
is most likely.
Of course, you want
to be organized
and methodical so
all abnormal and
unexpected findings
are identified.
OK.
Next, let's move on
to data acquisition.
So data acquisition
really is a system
which helps you narrow
the focus of the
differential diagnosis
based on a variety
of data. So what
are you compiling?
What are you putting
together? It uses
essentially clusters
of information. OK.
I'll give you an
example. Okay.
Take a child.
Child comes to your
office. A child is
tugging on their ear.
Okay. Child tugging
on their ear.
Mom reports that
they've been having some
tenderness in that
area. It's likely
to be associated
with that particular
anatomical structure
is where the diagnosis
will be likely coming
from. And that's
what we mean by
anatomical location. So
organizing interpreting
clinical information
involves approaches
to organizing
findings. As I said,
anatomic location,
cluster findings based
on the anatomical
relationship in the
body. Child comes to
your office, they're
tugging on the ear,
all the symptoms are
based in that region.
Common things occur
commonly. We can talk
about zebras down the
line, but when you
put your ear to the
ground and you're
hearing hoofbeats, you're
looking for a horse,
not always a zebra.
And when a child
comes in pulling in
the ear, you want to
think the most common
and logical things.
Two, age. What disease
processes are common
in different age
groups? Now, you might
want to acquire the
data in different ways.
So a child coming to
you with, let's say,
chest pain versus
a 45-year-old that
comes to you with chest
pain, the differential
is going to be
different based on the
age and epidemiology
of what type of person
develops chest pain
at those given ages.
So age is important
with data acquisition
because it leads to
different differential
diagnoses based
on the categories.
Three,
timing of symptoms.
Knowing how different
disease processes as
well as duration of
certain disease is
definitely important.
Now, sometimes diseases
can last, you know,
a couple of minutes.
Symptoms can last a
few minutes to a few
hours. They can last
two days to three
months. Knowing that
that timing will often
give a much broader
idea or a much more
narrow idea, I should
say, of what the
likely diagnosis will
be. And, of course,
involvement in body
systems. Now, if a
patient reports chest
pain, you're likely
going to want to start
with the cardiovascular
system and then
branch your way out
asking some basic
associated symptoms.
But if a patient comes
to you with just a
constitutional
complaint, such as fever,
night sweats,
unexplained weight
loss for six months,
these are much
broader kind of
complaints that
would lead to a wider
variety of involvement
of different body
systems or multi
-system conditions.
So your differential
is going to be much
over a broader scope
than narrow, where
if it's a child
coming in, as I said
before, with an ear
tug or a 45-year-old
with chest pain
radiating to their jaw
or to their left
shoulder, those types of
things are much
more narrow focused,
but the broader we
get, the more wide, you
know, much more
larger blanket we need
to use to cover all
the possibilities.
So how do we organize and
interpret some of
this information?
Well, we also
want to look at
accurate problem
presentation.
So what does this
exactly mean,
right?
This is also the
student. This is also the
student that
essentially sums up your
assessment, right, of
the patient with the
corresponding reasoning
as to why the physician
feels that this is
the correct diagnosis.
So we want to present
the problem with
the case. So synthesizing
and developing
the problem presentation.
You basically make
sense of all the
information gathered
to this point and form
a problem presentation
or clinical picture.
It's almost like
a one or two sentence
oral presentation
based on the combined
information given.
It concludes the
initial information,
such as chief complaint,
epidemiology,
and risk factors,
also the key features
in the history
and physical
exam, as well as
the results of
diagnostic testing.
In your clinical
documentation, the
problem presentation
is also called the
summary statement
that often starts
the assessment
section of your note,
okay? There's also,
you can review this in
Box 5, 2, and Bates
3rd edition and try
writing a problem
presentation of your own.
Generation of
a hypothesis.
Now, what exactly
do we mean here?
Okay. can you begin?
This goes to what is
the thought process
behind when you
start to actually
determine what the
differential is, all
right? So a lot of
times what we'll
have you do is before
we even give you
the case, before we
even go through the
scenario where, as
we do in DPR lab,
one of your pod
leader will play the
patient, and all of
you will work together
in a round-robin
format to ask the
appropriate questions
in an interview format.
Before we even do
that, we give you the
doorway information,
which is the vitals,
and we ask you just
based on the vitals, what
can you put together as
a possible hypothesis?
So we want you to
start to gather and
start the CDM, the
clinical decision-making
process, before you
even see the patient,
before you even walk in
the room. We want you
to start generating
hypotheses. Yes, they'll
be broad. For instance,
if we give you a
set of vitals and all
there is is a fever,
that'll give you some
idea that there could
be some infectious
process going on. But
obviously, without
having seen or spoken to
the patient yet, there's
still such a broad
range of what the possible
differential could
be. But as soon as
they tell you the chief
complaint, as soon as
you start to ask you
questions, this is
what I mean by you'll
start to be able to really
narrow down eliminating
certain possibilities,
including and
excluding others and
ultimately getting to a
clinical decision okay
so here we go generating
that hypothesis
for each identified
problem or cluster of
problems you want to
generate the clinical
hypothesis for the
underlying cause or
diagnosis as i said you start
by just looking at
the basic doorway
information you you give
yourself a differential
or some thoughts as
to what could be going
then once you start to
interview the patient
you do the same thing
and you can narrow
each time you start
more broad and you get
more narrow as you go
through. Again, in Bates'
book Box 5.3, here's
some approaches for
searching for probable
causes of findings.
How do we determine
or make a composite
list, if you will, of
a differential based on
just a general number
of findings, okay?
Generating exhaustive
lists is the first
thing, and then matching
findings against
all conditions that
can produce them.
Ultimately, as
we go through our
interview, we will
be able to eliminate
diagnostic
possibilities that
will fail to explain
those findings.
Then we want to weigh the
competing possibilities
and select the most
likely diagnosis,
given special attention
to potentially
life-threatening
conditions.
So what am I
referring to here?
So what we want to
do is this is a great
tool, a great memory
aid for a patient who,
let's say, presents with
a diagnosis, a chief
complaint of chest
pain. Okay, let's just
take chest pain.
Here's a memory aid for
generating a differential
diagnosis. This is
an exhaustive method.
So if a doctor says,
what's the differential
on a patient with
chest pain? What you
do is you're using
mnemonics such as this.
There are many, many
mnemonics. I learned
different ones in my
residency. I used one
called vitamin C and D,
but here's two well
-constructed acronyms or
mnemonics, if you
will, that give you a
full layout for
generating a differential
diagnosis. So patient
comes to you with chest
pain and you're trying
to include what the
possible differential
could be without
knowing anything else.
You go through this list
and it includes all
the various systems
and etiologies for where
this chest pain can
be generated from. And
you start with, the
one on the left here
is Tom G. Prince, MD,
and that includes
toxins and trauma,
oncologic. So chest
pain, let's say it could
be a myxoma, tumor
in the heart, right?
MSK, rheumatologic,
okay? It could be, you
know, pericarditis, or
not pericarditis, but
yeah, it could be a
costochondritis for
chest pain. GI. So for
a patient presenting
with chest pain, it
could be GERD, right?
For pulmonary, it
could be a pulmonary
embolism. So what I mean
is you're going through
this list with the
chief complaint of chest
pain and trying to
correlate a specific
diagnosis based on all
the systems presented
here. This is a great
tool to use as a
third and fourth year
medical student on
preclinical rotations,
as well as on rounds.
Like I said, once you
memorize this and get
familiar with how
you can degenerated
differential, this is
really going to help you on
the road going into
your preclinical
rotations. The one on the
right is just a different
form. It's a little
less exhaustive,
but still is very
inclusive with the various
acronyms that it uses,
such as Vindicate,
vascular, infectious,
neoplastic, drug-related,
inflammatory, idiopathic,
iatrogenic, which
is doctor induced and
then finally congenital
autoimmune or allergic
and trauma toxic
or endocrine and
metabolic so like i said
pick anyone you don't
have to pick you
know five of them you
pick one that works for
you that's comprehensive
and thorough i
like tom g prince md
i use vitamin c and d
as well i can go over
that in class but
there's many many different
ones that are used
by students throughout.
So keep this in
mind and pick one that
really works for you.
So generating the
hypothesis or differential
diagnosis. For each
identified problem or
cluster of problems,
you will generate a
clinical hypothesis for
the underlying thoughts.
So again, box three,
approaching to search
for probable cause of
the findings. As I said,
we generated our
list as we did in the
previous slides. We match
the findings against
all conditions. And
then the last two points
here, weighing
competing possibilities,
selecting the most likely
diagnosis, and giving
special attention, as
we said earlier, to
potentially life-threatening
conditions because
we don't want to miss
that. I'll share a
brief story with you.
It's a very famous story
about a composer, a
Broadway composer,
Jonathan Larson, who
wrote the play Rent. The
week before the play was
to come out, actually
the night before, he
presented to the ER in
a city hospital
complaining of chest pain.
The doctors examined
him, they did a thorough
examination, and
their initial feelings
was that it was either
an infection or something
that they gave him
some aspirin and some
medication to go home
with, which he did.
That night, he
went home and he
ended up collapsing
on the floor
and dying from an
aortic aneurysm.
His aorta split open
and he bled out and
died at home. And it
was missed. And the
fact is, this is
one of those cases
where you needed to
consider a possible or
potentially life
-threatening situation.
These sorts of
things, although
rare, you don't
want to miss it. And
if there's any
suspicion at all,
trust your gut,
weigh all the
information that's
presented to you, and
make sure you do a
thorough evaluation
before coming
to a conclusion.
Okay. Okay.
Next part of this
will be search for and
selection of an
illness script. So
what is an illness
script? It's something
that we're going to
start to introduce
to you moving
forward in the coming
weeks and certainly
in the next semester.
And I will explain
a little bit about
what they are if you
haven't heard of them.
An illness script,
excuse me, is an
organized mental
summary of a clinician's
knowledge of a
disease. It essentially
lays out everything
about that disease
in a very short
fashion that gives you
the bullet points.
It'll include
pathophysiology of the
disease, epidemiology,
time course,
salient symptoms
and signs,
diagnostic tests
used to diagnose, as
well as the treatments
for that particular
disease. And at
NYTCOM, we also
will include osteopathic
considerations,
which is something
you could find in
some of your texts
and resources here
at the library and
in your OMM course.
now close your
eyes let's try
this example when
you close your
eyes and picture
a firetruck
what does it
look like to you
what color is it
what's the shape
of it i'll give
you a moment
is this sort of what
you picture obviously
we have the red truck
we have the ladder
this is something
we've seen over the
course of all of our
lives as young children
adults hearing the
sounds you can almost
picture the sounds
and that that
fire truck moving you
know down the road
right so this is
something you've
seen on tv shows
you've seen in person
you know who's driving
it you know when when
they're coming about
when there's a fire
right so this is
something you're used to
seeing now what if i
showed you this picture
instead and asked you
to tell me what it is
now it doesn't look
anything like the one
i just showed you It's
yellow. I don't see
a ladder. I don't see
any firemen. But the
fact is, this is a
firetruck, okay? Not one
that we're normally
used to seeing. So the
equivalent of this is
what I talked a little
bit about before,
like zebras. We know
what we expect to see
based on heuristics,
mental shortcuts, and
our history of looking
for things and knowing
what to expect when
we hear certain key
words, catchphrases.
All right, that's the
heuristics I mentioned
earlier. But sometimes
you do get zebras,
and this is not something
that you would have
expected, but it's
also a firetruck, and
it's important to
note. And what's the
correlation of this? The
fact is, similar diagnoses
and assessments
that present with a
chief complaint can often
present differently,
but ultimately lead to
the same conclusion.
And it's important
to evaluate each case
individually, looking
at all the data and
not making assumptions,
although it's easy
to base it on our
history of utilizing the
same data we've had in
previous cases, because
everything's based
on our knowledge and
experiences. But as
we start to put that
together, we want to
become more cognizant of
those zebras, of the
things that are presenting
slightly off or
differently that won't
always appear as the
classic case, right?
You know, if someone
presents with chest
pain radiating to the
jaw, we know what we're
thinking. It's like
that fire truck, that
red fire truck. We know
that it could be an
MI, it could be something
cardiac related.
But if I tell you
that the patient just
feels, it's an older
patient that presents
with fatigue, and they
just feel a little
lightheaded, and they have
a history of diabetes,
turns out they could
still have an MI.
Because a lot of
times, older patients
don't always
necessarily present with
chest pain. And it may
not always be in the
same presentation,
but ultimately it
would be the same
diagnosis. The point is
that you need to gather
all the information,
put together the
whole history to
come up with a conclusion
without jumping
to conclusions, if
that makes sense.
Components of the
illness script, okay?
As I talked about,
this is a sample
illness script. So
this is an illness
script on community
-acquired pneumonia,
all right? It
includes epidemiology
and pathophysiology,
and you see what
increases the
person's risk with,
the time course,
how long it lasts,
The salient signs
and symptoms, fever,
cough, shortness of
breath, tachycardia, and
so on and so forth.
What diagnostic labs
are used to diagnose
community-acquired
pneumonia and ultimately
the treatments. As I
said before, we would
also include osteopathic
considerations, which
will include what
somatic dysfunctions
most likely present
in the case, What
findings would you would
you consider pneumonia
for or what what
somatic dysfunctions
are most commonly
associated with that
particular disease state?
OK,
last component or key
element. This is the
diagnosis. Right. So
this comes down to
how do we reach our
ultimate conclusion?
Right.
Assessment of
diagnosis. Now, from a
documentation standpoint,
and this is something
that you'll be doing,
going into your CSAs,
going into the Ferrara
Center and simulation
lab encounters that
you'll be doing through
this year and next year.
Once you go through
these cases and
ultimately complete and
compile an entire SOAP
note, this is still
early on in your careers
as medical students,
but starting later on
in your spring semester,
in this semester,
you're going to be asked
to compose the
assessment and diagnosis.
And when we write an
assessment, you always
want to list the diagnosis
in the assessment
section of the
note. Now, what does
this include? The
diagnosis may be very
straightforward. It
could also be more
challenging and require
further information to
get to that file
diagnosis if there are
multiple causes for the
patient's condition.
You want to be
as specific as
the data will
allow. For example,
subarachnoid
hemorrhage, unspecified
versus subarachnoid
hemorrhage,
left temporal lobe.
As you can see,
there's different
ways to label it.
A simple diagnosis.
So for an assessment,
the patient presents
with chest pain,
as we've used this
example before. What
could the diagnosis
be? It could be
stable angina. It could
be unstable angina.
It could be
myocardial infarction.
pericarditis. It could be
gastroesophageal
reflux disease or GERD.
There's a large number
of possibilities
in the differential
diagnosis, but you
want to be as specific
as possible based
on the information
provided in the note.
You don't want to
give a diagnosis such
as dehydration or
weight loss. Those are
more symptoms or part
of a problem list.
So you really want
to put the assessment
as your most likely
diagnosis based on
the information provided
to your ultimate
conclusion that you're
trying to reach.
Now, planning the
diagnostic and treatment
strategies. The plan
of care should be
logical flow from your
working diagnosis listed
in the assessment
section of your note.
What does the plan
always include? So once
you've done your
assessment, now you have
to compose a plan based
on that diagnosis.
These are not always,
this is not an
exhaustive list, but
includes many of the things
that you will find
as part of your plan.
And when you're
writing your soap note,
these are the
components. You can start
with laboratory tests
that allow you to
differentiate
between two potential
diagnoses and guide your
therapeutic management
of the patient.
This could be a CDC,
a CHEM-12. If you're,
as I said, with
chest pain and you're
concerned about a
possible MI, you
would order cardiac
enzymes, troponin, and
so on and so forth.
Diagnostic
interventions would be
the next component,
and that could
include x-rays,
CAT scans, MRIs,
VQ scans to rule out
a pulmonary embolism,
to rule out a deep
venous thrombosis
or a DVT. We might
want to do Doppler
ultrasounds of the
lower extremities.
So those are the
types of diagnostic
interventions that
we're talking about.
Patient education
or counseling.
Every single plan
that you write, you
would want to include
counseling. And what
are you going to
counsel the patient?
Now, there's a lot
of things you can
counsel patients
on, and I promise
there's always something
you could find,
even if it's not
always apparent.
So some of the things
that are very common
are found in the social
history of the patient,
the fed tacos we
often talk about. That
could be diet. That
could be eating a better
diet. Picking a
specific diet is always
something that you can
do. Get comfortable with
understanding either
the DASH diet, the
Mediterranean diet,
or any one of the more
approved diets that you
can have a good working
knowledge of and
educate keep the patient
on that will help them
in their counseling.
You can counsel them
on smoking or tobacco
or illicit drug or
even caffeine cut down
or cessation. So
cutting down on anything
that could be considered
a risk factor for
causing whatever
symptoms they may have,
which is to improve
the overall quality of
life. These are things
you want to counsel
them on. Other things
you can counsel them on
are even in the
healthcare maintenance
component. You can
actually counsel patients
on, you know, if they're
a 50-year-old male
and they had a father
that had colon cancer,
yet they've never had
a colonoscopy, you
can counsel them on
healthcare maintenance
and understanding
that it's about time
that they consider
getting a colonoscopy,
especially since there
should have gotten one
at 45 or 50. But still,
it's something that
you can help to
work on counseling a
patient, not just for
the components of the
social history that may
be, you know, a little
bit more of an outlier
or even, like I
said, the healthcare
maintenance components.
A woman who's 50
years old, has never
had a mammography
or is behind in
their testing for
certain types of
cancer. Those are
the types of things
that you can counsel
them on as well.
Medication changes.
All right. So
take a patient
who's hypertensive.
They've been on
medications, but they
come in and their
blood pressure has
been running high for
the last few visits.
you want to
consider changing,
increasing, or altering
their medications.
So that's something
else you can
counsel and work on
with them as well.
So again, patient
comes in with chest
pain, you find
out that you're
concerned about a
possible MI, and because
they have a lot
of risk factors,
you're going to
want to refer them,
probably to a cardiologist,
let's say, for
an echo and a stress
test. So referring a
patient out to a
specialist is something
else you want to consider
here. um also the
follow visit every
single note should
always have a follow
visit and it should be
fairly specific to the
working diagnosis if
a patient comes in
with chest pain and
you're trying to
rule out a myocardial
infarction you're not
going to want to come have
them come back in
four months or six
months you want to have
them come back within
the net within the
past within the next
two to four weeks or
sooner depending on when
they you referral
to the cardiologist
occurs where you can
review their lab work
and whatever testing
might have been done.
Now, the one thing
that's not mentioned here
that I did want to
include is pretty much
every plan should also
include or offer OMT
or osteopathic manipulative
treatment based
on the OSC, the
osteopathic structural
exam that was given in
your objective note.
So make sure that you
do include that as
well. And of course,
looking at this, you want
to make sure that the
plan is safe, that
it's cost-effective,
that you're not doing
unnecessary testing
based on the setting that
you're in. Now, again,
we talk about chest
pain. If you don't
think it might really
be a chest pain that's
a cardiac event, and
it might just be
gastroesophageal reflux,
and you're thinking,
all right, maybe I want
to order cardiac
enzymes. Be mindful that
you wouldn't order
cardiac enzymes in a
setting like a clinic.
You'd want to actually
refer the patient to
an ER or someplace
where they can be closely
monitored, especially
if you're trying to
rule out a significant
event, if those risk
factors give you the
reason to want to do
a testing like that.
Diagnostic errors.
Diagnostic errors
have been implicated
in 15% of
clinical decisions
with medical-legal
repercussions, and this
goes to the case that
I mentioned before.
And a lot of times
it's doctors who use
either System 1 or System
2. Sometimes doctors
feel very confident
in system one. They
don't use as much logic
and reasoning, but
because they have so
much experience seeing
a patient with that
particular presentation,
they kind of use
more of a narrow
provincial approach, if
you will, towards the
diagnostic process,
such as I mentioned
with the Jonathan
Morrison case. Of course,
it was an outlier and
a zebra, and maybe
not every patient
presents with chest pain
that's automatically
considered a searing
aortic aneurysm. But
the fact of the matter
is, it's something
that you need to
consider if any of the
other signs are there.
Misdiagnosis is the
potential to cause serious
harm to patients as
it sets up a cascade
of subsequent mistreatments.
You start with
one wrong thing, and
then it cascades down
into a litany of other
treatments that kind of
takes the patient,
veers them off course
from what the original
likely diagnosis would
have been. All right.
General medical counsel
and other entities
advocate that med students
need to be equipped
with critical thinking
skills in order to
identify their own
cognitive biases and
those the clinicians they
rotate with. So just
keep all these things
in mind. You know, as
you go through your four
years, you're going to
be using both of the
systems we talked
about, the heuristic
system, as well as a
hypothetical approach as
well, more logical and
time consuming, but more
thought provoking
approach. And both systems
are important, but
you need to be able to
kind of discern without,
you don't want to
make, jump to the
conclusions, you don't want
to pigeonhole yourself
into one specific
diagnosis and always try
to leave your options
open and always consider
other possibilities,
whether they be life
-threatening or not.
common diagnostic errors
here's some kind of
clinical errors or
cognitive errors we often
see um give you an
example you have anchoring
bias here tendency
to potentially lock
onto salient features
in the patient's initial
presentation too early
in the diagnostic
process this is something
that we often do
you know patient presents
with back pain you
often think of one
thing we don't we might
think it's just a lumbar
sprain but we also
don't we're not going
to run conclusion that
he's having a searing
aortic annulus. I'll
give you an example
other than yet here.
The clinician locks onto
a patient's description
of an aura that
perceives their headache
as indicative of a
migraine and fails to
recognize red flags of
increased intracranial
pressure that could
prompt neuroimaging for
this patient. You
know, we see or hear
certain things that
trigger a diagnosis from
something you learned
in med school, but we
need to encompass all
the components of the
doorway information and
the vitals to all the
subtle nuances in the
case that could lead
us to possible other
diagnoses. We'll do
another example here,
availability heuristics.
Assumption that a
diagnosis is more likely
or more frequently
occurring is more readily
going to come to mind,
such as we say with
that mental shortcut
we talk about. And the
example here is in a
clinician who has recently
seen several patients
who present with
maybe right lower quadrant
pain that's indicative
of acute appendicitis
does not consider
ovarian torsion in
an adolescent girl
presenting with acute
right lower quadrant pain.
You know, we see
things, we hear things,
we're experienced in
certain components of what
we see on a regular
basis that we tend not
to always include the
epidemiology or the
age or ***, gender, or
the patient that might
actually play into the
possible diagnosis.
Confirmation bias, seeking
supportive evidence
for diagnosis at the
exclusion of a more
persuasive information
that can refute it.
So the example here
is a clinician makes a
presumptive diagnosis
of a URI and a well
-appearing patient
presenting with a cough,
rhinorrhea, and fever,
but doesn't consider
pneumonia even after
finding an asymmetric chest
wall excursion and
don't list the chest
percussion on examination.
We want to take all
the knowledge that we
we gather in the entire
subjective and objective
components to get
the best diagnostic
possible and it's hard
not to want to you know
jump to conclusions
because we get excited
we want to we oh yeah
i read about that in
med school i i got this
this is oh they got
rebound they got guarding
they got pain in the
right little quadrant
this is definitely
you know appendicitis
or whatever it might
be so you always want
to keep an open mind
move slowly don't let
heuristics take over
and don't use as much
logic and reasoning
to confirm what you're
thinking is. And as long
as you use the right
amount of both systems,
then you'll be okay.
So let's go down to
one more down here.
Let's go to representation
error. Failure
to take prevalence
into account when
estimating the
probability of diagnosis.
Okay. Clinician often
sees older patients,
places diverticular
bleed high on the
differential when
evaluating ******
bleeding in an adolescent
patient. This is
common in the clinic,
especially if you're
used to seeing the
same epidemiology or
age patients. If
you're a geriatrician,
let's say, you're
going to see a lot of
GI bleeds possibly
due to diverticulitis.
If you happen to see
a younger patient,
your mindset, you
jump to what your
experiences are based
on those diagnoses
without incorporating
the epidemiology and
statistics of a
younger population. And
you need to kind of
put it all into play.
Okay.
So this is just a
couple of samples.
You can look through
these on your
own as well and
realize that it's so
easy to jump to
conclusions if you don't
use the proper
thought processes.
Okay.
Reviewing steps
and strategies
for clinical reasoning.
Starting again,
like I said, data
gathering, history
taking, physical exam,
results of the
investigation. Then we
do our problem
presentation, highlighting
the key features
of clinical and
investigated data
and synthesizing all
this data to formulate
a clear story.
Then we do our hypothesis
generation with
the acronyms I
mentioned before, with
that exhaustive list
of differentials.
Obviously, you want
to prioritize the
list based on the
clinical knowledge
and formulating
the most likely and
least likely
diagnoses based on the
information presented
in each case.
Then we talk about
the illness scripts,
right? searching for
illness scripts generated
from prior clinical
experiences. It's a
great way thing you
can save, collect them,
use them to help
study, but also gives
you all the data you
need for that particular
disease process
and applying that
knowledge appropriately
to whatever current
patient has based on
their chief complaints.
And then finally,
your diagnosis.
Sorting through all
this data, applying
your knowledge from
the illness scripts,
narrowing the
differential based on the
information you gathered,
and generating a possible
final or at least
a likely diagnosis
if possible now what
we'll do is we'll have
you practice i will
stop here i will give
you i will put the
slides up and i'd like
you to kind of practice
these cases okay
this is one case and
it's going to use all
your applied knowledge
from the last few
slides so i'm going to
leave about 10 seconds
with each slide i'll
let you practice this
and you can kind of
do this on your own
And if you have any
questions, don't
hesitate to reach out
to me. It's been a
pleasure imparting this
information to you,
and I hope this has
been helpful. And you
can reach out to me.
My email address is
on the first slide.
So I'll leave about
10 seconds with each
of the next few slides
to allow you to pause
it and then save
it and practice what
we went over today.